if you want to create your own chrome
extension you're in the right place
in this course raman will teach you how
to create a chrome extension using the
new iteration of the web extensions
platform which is called manifest v3
raman is a great instructor
and he works for pieces.app pieces.app
provided a grant that made this course
possible but you don't have to use their
extension to follow along share in the
comments what type of chrome extension
you want to make now the reason i want
to teach about this particular topic is
i've created two web extensions in my
career
the first is for a previous company
where my extension generated a
significant amount of revenue for the
company and the second for my current
company pieces
where our web extensions play a critical
part of our product stack and help
developers across the globe boost their
productivity
i'm going to be using the pieces web
extensions and integrations quite a bit
in this video so if you're interested in
downloading an ai coding assistant that
helps you save and reuse code snippets
convert screenshots to code and more go
ahead and download pieces in the
description and you can totally follow
along so during my journey as a chrome
extension developer i had often noticed
that tutorials and stack overflow
answers were using outdated versions of
the web extensions platform
my hope for you after you leave this
video is that you have a resource to
create a modern chrome extension and you
understand the difference between
the newer version of the web extensions
platform manifest v3 and older versions
now before we get started there's going
to be three prerequisites to this course
the first is required and it's that you
have a basic understanding of javascript
and dom manipulation
the second is optional if you want to
follow along with this video and code
alongside with me you can go to the
description below i'm going to have a
link to my github repo go ahead and get
cloned that and you'll be able to follow
along
the third is also optional if you
totally want to follow along you can go
ahead to pieces.app and install a pieces
ide integration along with the pieces
web extension and you'll be able to use
pieces exactly the way i do in this
video
with that let's get started so as i
mentioned before the extension we're
going to create is a youtube bookmarker
basically anytime you navigate to a
youtube video page an icon will show up
on your youtube video player to allow
you to bookmark a particular time stamp
on any video
so let me show you how that's going to
work
if you're on a youtube video page you're
going to see this item at the bottom
right you can go ahead and click that
and if you navigate to your chrome
extension icon at the top right i have a
pin so it's showing in the toolbar
you're gonna see a new timestamp i
already had one timestamp for 50 minutes
i added one with an hour 18.
i can go ahead and delete this one
because i just decided i don't want it
and our extension is going to give us
that ability to do that
now if i want to go back to my 50 minute
time stamp you can click the play button
and it goes directly back to that
particular timestamp
i can also delete this one too and when
there is no bookmarks to show it's going
to say there's no bookmarks to show
now i'm going to add one
just so we have one on this video and i
can show you how storage works i'm going
to navigate to a new video
and in this video we have no bookmarks
so it says there's no bookmarks to show
but if we go back to our previous video
where we saved a bookmark
it's going to load that previous
bookmark
now the last thing is if you navigate to
a non-youtube video page
it's going to say this is not a youtube
video page in the extension ui
and that's basically all the
capabilities of this chrome extension
we're going to build out here there's
going to be a lot more you can do on
your own afterwards now i also want to
mention the reason we're working on
creating this extension in particular is
because it's going to show you all the
major parts of creating a chrome
extension it's going to show you how to
work with a content script to manipulate
the dom it's going to show you how to
create a ui for your extension it's
going to show you how to use service
workers as background scripts which is a
major part of the shift from manifest v2
to manifest v3
and to start working on the extension
once you've get cloned my repo you can
go ahead and click on the puzzle piece
in your chrome browser at the top right
click manage extensions i'm going to go
ahead and remove my extension show i can
show you how it works
and you're going to see this developer
mode option at the top right go ahead
and toggle that so it's on
click load unpacked
then go to the repo that you get clone
to mine with the boilerplate code
go ahead and load that
and we're gonna see our extension here
if we click on this puzzle piece and pin
it
what we're gonna see is this basic ui
it's just gonna say your bookmarks for
this video with no bookmarks and it's
just going to show up everywhere
this is the default messaging in the
boilerplate code i supplied and the
boilerplate code will also contain all
the files you need to follow along
the best place to start with creating
our extension is the manifest.json file
this file is a json file where we can
specify what version of the extension's
platform we will use among other
information that is going to serve as
defaults for loading in our extensions
also every extension you would want to
create whether it's safari mozilla or
any chromium based extension will need a
manifest.json file and it's probably the
single most important file in your
extension
because it simply just won't work
without it
in our boilerplate code i already added
the manifest.json file so we don't have
to spend too long writing it out i think
it would be especially helpful if i just
point out some of the things that you
should note
in case you're creating your own
extension so let's take a look here as
you'd suspect
there's a name there's a version number
and a description
and basically the version number is
going to populate when you load in the
extension
the name you see is also going to be the
name of the extension when you load it
in and the description is pretty
self-explanatory it's just a description
of what the extension does now things
get more interesting with the
permissions
the permissions will be different
depending on whatever chrome extension
you're building
for this particular extension we're
going to request two permissions
which is going to be the permission to
use the chrome dot storage api and the
chrome dot tabs api the chrome dot
storage api is to store things in the
user's browser for the extension and the
second permission which is the
chrome.tabs api
is what helps us access our browser's
tab system
so we can read the tab for the extension
this is basically going to help us
identify what browser tab the user is
currently using and grab the url to see
if they are on a youtube video page for
our extension now the host permissions
just give you the ability to send course
requests to certain host names our
extension only deals with youtube pages
so i have a match pattern written here
just for youtube the service worker as i
mentioned before there's a big change
between extensions v2 and v3 and one of
the big changes is the use of a service
worker
as you can see here the other is the
ability to use promises but let's just
focus on service workers for right now
service workers are just a javascript
file that runs separately from the main
browser thread
this means that your service worker will
not have access to content of a web page
since it is separate from main processes
however your service worker does have
capabilities to speak to your extension
using the extensions messaging system
which we will see and use in our
bookmarking extension
the next thing i want to point out is
the content scripts
the content scripts are just files that
run in context of the web pages we're on
we're going to use this to manipulate
the dom of our web page that our
extension is looking at
and here we're just specifying that our
content script is represented by our
content script.js file
as you can see with the
jscollingcontentscript.js
the last thing i want to point out is
the popup.html file down here
under default popup
this just specifies which file was
served as our ui in our case we've
specified the popup.html file and in
that file we specify that the
corresponding file that helps it with
its interactivity is the popup.js file
with all that out of the way let's get
to coding the actual extension
we're now finally going to start writing
code to make our extension work
for us to even test the extension we
have to add the button of the youtube
player that will allow us to save
bookmarks with timestamps
so in order for us to add a button on
the youtube video player we'll have to
manipulate the dom of the webpage we are
on what that means is we'll have to
write our logic in our content script
file which operates in the context of
the web page as i mentioned before so
let's go ahead and add some code to our
content script file
we're going to go ahead and add the
following variables
youtube
left controls
and youtube
player
one is going to be for accessing the
youtube player one is going to be for
accessing the controls and this is going
to allow us to manipulate each of these
but before we continue writing the logic
to do dom manipulation in the context
script
we also have to think about how our
extension is even going to know when
we've navigated to a new web page and we
need to know this so the content script
knows to execute logic to add the plus
icon to add bookmarks for our extension
let's go ahead and go in our
background.js file now
and what we want to do here is listen to
any updates in our tab system and find
the most recent tab or the tab that
we're on currently and see if it's a
youtube page
so we're going to have a listener
that's going to listen to tabs and if
you remember we got permissions to
access the chrome.tabs api
and we're going to listen for
an update two tabs
the parameters we're given is a tab id
and a tab
what we're gonna do from here is see if
there's a tab url and if there is a tab
url
let's see if that url includes
youtube.com
watch
the way i came up with that
is if you look at our youtube video
every individual video has youtube slash
watch
and we just want to make sure we're on a
page that has that specifically as a url
then what we want to do is set our query
parameters
and we're going to use query parameters
as a unique id for each video so we can
grab it from storage
you'll see what i mean in a second and
i'll show you
so we're gonna do that by using the
javascript split method
what that means is basically after
this question mark query parameter
we're going to grab this value
and this is going to be our unique video
value this right here after the equal
sign and every video on youtube has a
different value right here
so it's a pretty unique key that will
help us store videos uniquely as well in
our storage and it's consistent
so then we're going to add
url parameters
and this is just an interface to work
with url's url search params
and the final thing we want to do
is there's a messaging system that
happens between the extension we're
going to send a message to our content
script that basically says a new video
has loaded
and this is the video id of that video
and the video id being that unique video
value that we saw in the url on youtube
and this tab id send message usage that
i'm doing right here is all directly
from documentation
the send message takes a tab id it takes
a unique object
so right now i'm going to type type and
this is the type of event is a new video
event
and then a video id value
which is going to be url
parameters
dot get
v
so if we're doing url get b it's going
to grab this right here
and that's basically going to be the
code for that but send message takes a
tab id it takes an object and then it
could also take a callback function
this object right here doesn't have to
be type or video id it could also be
something random like i could literally
pass
this and the content script will have
access to random
and then the string random
in our case the only thing that's
applicable
is the type of the event and then the
video id which the content script needs
now in our content script we're going to
add a listener that
is going to listen to any of those
incoming messages we need to be able to
listen to that background.js message so
to do that we're going to end up writing
the following code
to add that listener so we're going to
say on message
add listener
and this is going to accept
three parameters so an object a sender
and a response
and the response is when a message is
being sent to the content script we can
also send a response back where the
message is coming from
so i'm going to destructure those values
we're getting
and if you remember the way i'm
deconstructing type value video id
is basically we're given a video id
right here
later on we're going to grab a value as
well and i'm just destructuring so
each of these are its own variable
so i'm going to say if type is equal to
new so
if the type of event is new video loaded
which we're getting from the
background.js file
we want to be able to set
current video
which will be a global variable in the
content script
as
the video id
and then we want to call a function to
handle any actions
with new videos so we're gonna call a
new video loaded function
and let's go ahead and set current video
as a top level variable
and that's just going to be an empty
string but
it's going to be set as the string set
from the background.js file
once the message is received on this end
so let's go ahead and actually see if
this works at all
i'm going to go ahead and
adjust contour.log
url parameters
i'm going to give this a reload
open this
let's inspect it
and we have our url search parameters so
we know we're getting our url search
parameters now
great so so far things look good
now what we want to do from here
is create that new video loaded function
and after we create this function and
all the functionality surrounding it
we should see the youtube player button
on the youtube video
so let's go ahead and do that so what
we're going to do is
create this function that we have right
here called new video loaded
and what we probably want to do is check
if a bookmark button already exists i
know the class name that this item has
it's called bookmark button because i
wrote the css code that's going to style
this whole extension so you could just
copy this part right here but
this is just some native
dom
[Music]
javascript
methods that we can use
it's actually going to be by class name
and it's going to return an html
collection so what we're going to do is
grab the first element that matches this
class name bookmark button
and it's just going to exist on every
single youtube video page
so if we want to test that we could just
say console.log bookmark button exists
and let's reload this page and inspect
it
actually let's reload our extension as
well
this page
inspect
we're probably
going to get undefined this is exactly
what i expected
because we don't have any logic
surrounding the bookmark button yet and
also we're not even setting a bookmark
button right now so if the bookmark
button did exist we would get true it
does exist but we're getting undefined
right now
so what we want to do if we're getting
that undefined or false value that a
bookmark button does not exist
is
add some logic to say hey let's add this
bookmark button to any youtube player
so we're going to create an image
element
that is going to be
the image we click on for bookmark
buttons
and as part of this book
and we're going to add a couple
attributes
the first thing we're going to want to
do is pull the image
that we're using which is
our assets
bookmark
png you already have this if you're
following along with the boilerplate
code
the second thing we want to do is
add a class
and the way we're going to add this
class is basically
um make it pretty dynamic here so we're
going to add a youtube button class
with a space and then
we're going to add a bookmark button
class
in
quotes and this is again just some
styling i have that you don't need to
worry about right now
and the last thing we want to do is
basically on hover we want to make a
title show
so we're just going to say the title is
click to bookmark
current
timestamp and this is just a ui thing
you'll see this in a bit
next what we want to show is a way to
grab
the youtube controls
so these are the youtube controls over
here
we want to be able to grab these left
controls so we can add a bookmark button
right here
so let's go ahead and find out how to do
that
i already know
how to grab this so i'm going to show
you how this works you can inspect
elements right here and find what
elements they exactly are
but basically we're going to use native
javascript methods like we have done
previously to grab those controls and
insert our button if i do
document.getelements
by classname
and i grab youtube
left
controls
we should get
an element back which is going to be
this div class over here
and you can see that it gives us all the
left controls over here where we're
going to add our button and the second
thing we're going to want to do is grab
the youtube player as well and that's
one of the global variables we set in
our content script and we can also do
that
by writing document dot get
elements
by class name
and then there's this video stream
class
and we're gonna grab the one at the
zerowith index
and it grabs a whole youtube component
right there so now we know the two
elements in the dom we need to
manipulate but let's set those elements
first we're going to do exactly what we
saw in our console over there
document.get
actually i'm just going to go back and
copy these
way easier so i don't make a mistake
and then the second one is going to be
youtube player
go back and copy that
okay
so after this what we're going to want
to do is add that bookmark button and we
grab the controls you saw that row in
the player we want to add it to that row
so we're going to type out youtube left
controls to get those left controls we
stored in a variable
and use this native javascript method we
can use called append child
which is going to append
this bookmark element inside that row
and then the second thing we're going to
want to do is probably add a listener to
listen to any clicks on our icon so
there's a correction i want to make to
this portion of the video before we
continue it's going to be very important
in order for your extension to work
functionally
and
it's only one line of code but it's
going to make such a big difference
i'm also going to explain an important
concept of chrome extensions that i
neglected while i was writing this
which is that in our manifest.json file
we have a match pattern
for our content script and basically the
match pattern we currently have checks
if any youtube.com video is loaded and
if it is we're injecting our content
script into the context of that webpage
so basically what that means is
anytime a youtube.com page shows up
we're running a bunch of logic
using our content script but the problem
right now is that our background.js file
is telling us when a new video is loaded
and the event listener we're using is on
updated which is just checking if this
url is updated
if you refresh this page the url is not
updated so this button actually isn't
going to show up and if you continue
coding without
this fix right here you're going to see
some edge cases that you might not like
so let's go ahead and fix this we're
going to do a super simple fix
it's not the best fix in the world but
it will fix
the problem here
we're just gonna call a new video loaded
anytime
our content script matches youtube.com
and what this is gonna do is call this
new video loaded function anytime
we hit that match pattern
the downside of this is now if the
background script sees it as a new video
using that on updated event listener and
there's a condition that the content
script is injected we're going to hit
this or call this new video loaded
function twice
you can fix this pretty easily by just
adding a conditional and make sure that
doesn't happen but to make sure everyone
is able to follow along with this
correction i will not be doing that here
and we'll just only be inserting this
one line of code calling the new video
loaded function luckily the only thing
our new video loaded function is doing
is adding the bookmark button to the
youtube player so there's going to be no
negative implications to calling it
twice since we have a condition that
checks if the button is already on the
player it's just not the most efficient
implementation which is fine for the
sake of this tutorial with that let's
continue with the rest of the video
there we go
we have the button right there
but right now if we click the button
it's not doing anything and there's a
reason for that the reason is that we
don't have any event listener listening
to a click on this particular button
let's go ahead and add the code for that
so what we're going to do is add an
event listener to listen to a click for
the button
and we're literally going to use the add
event listener method
listen for a click
and then call a function called add new
bookmark
event
handler and this is the function we have
not coded yet so
to make this function work we're going
to have to do the following
we're probably going to have to figure
out the timestamp
of the video at which point someone
presses the button this is basically
going to help us figure out what our
bookmark should be saved as in storage
according to its timestamp so how are we
going to do that how are we going to
figure out the youtube video timestamp
again youtube makes this pretty
accessible
it could be found as an attribute
so what we're going to want to do is
grab the youtube player
and we already have a global variable
that has it
but i'm just going to grab it again so
we can see how to do this in the console
i'm going to create a
youtube player variable in our console
okay now we have it saved
and then on youtube player there's going
to be
a property called current
time
and it's going to give us the current
time in seconds
and in order for us to save
our bookmark according to hours minutes
seconds
we're probably gonna also have to create
a function that converts seconds into
a standard time
of how it's displayed in youtube
so let's go ahead and start with all
those things
we're going to go ahead and add the
function add new bookmark event handler
we're going to use the exact property we
saw in our console
youtube player dot current time which is
going to give us the current time
then we're going to say okay now
this is only called when a new bookmark
is made so
let's create a new bookmark variable
and this is going to be an object that
has the time of the bookmark
and a description
and the descriptions are just going to
end up being
the title
that's going to be displayed
in the chrome extension
so it's going to be a dynamic
description and it's going to say
bookmark at
current time
however the problem is that this is in
seconds as we said before so we're going
to have to convert this so we're going
to use
a function called get time
i'm just going to insert it using pieces
so all i'm going to do is go over to
this get time function here
insert snippet and there it is
so now i'm able to convert my seconds
into time
and then the last thing i want to do
here is sync it to chrome storage
and what this is going to do is set
chrome storage
with each bookmark so basically
each video according to its video
identification number that we're
grabbing from the url
will also map back to a set of bookmarks
in chrome storage
so to do that we're going to do chrome
storage sync and again if you're
interested in this you can look at
documentation to find out
what this function takes
current video
it's important to remember that things
need to be stored in json
in chrome storage so i'm going to do
json stringify
all my current video bookmarks so i'm
actually going to add
a variable up here that's going to store
all current video bookmarks
in an array
and
i'm going to
spread that so we can
add a new bookmark to those set of
current video bookmarks and then the
last thing i want to do here is sort the
bookmarks by their save timestamp in our
chrome storage
so we're going to sort
a time and this is just coming from this
right here every bookmark is going to
have a time
and a description
so we're going to look at that and sort
accordingly
great
now if we reload our extension
we're going to see if it works as
expected and the way to see that is
basically
console.log
this new bookmark
let's do it
great that time it worked we just had to
give it another reload and we got a time
in seconds and a description
now the final thing i want to do is
complete this file before we go to the
ui and we want to make this fully
functional to fetch all bookmarks when a
new video is loaded to do this we're
going to grab asynchronously all
bookmarks from chrome storage which
means i'm going to write a promise that
resolves once we retrieve all bookmarks
so that code's going to look like this
i'm going to create it at the top here
and i'm going to say cons fetch
bookmarks
and i want to return a promise
so we can resolve this asynchronously
and within that promise i'm going to
fetch from chrome storage so
i'm going to do a chrome storage sink
and we did a set before to set crimp
storage we're going to get this time
our current video
it takes an object
and we're going to resolve
to find
any bookmarks
when indexing using our current video
so
basically look in storage to see if our
current video has any bookmarks
or if it exists in storage
that's what's happening right here
if it does exist we're going to
json.parse it because we
json.stringified before
if it doesn't
what we want to do is
return an empty array
and this should work
and we're really only going to add these
in two places which will be in our new
video loaded function
so we're going to make this async
and we're going to add a fetch bookmarks
so
actually we're just going to add this to
our current video bookmarks variable
and call await fetch bookmarks
async await is going to resolve this
promise
and then the second place we want to add
this is to our add new bookmarks event
handler
to basically handle this case and make
sure we're always using
the most up-to-date uh
set of bookmarks when destructuring
so we're going to do current video
bookmarks
equals await
fetch bookmarks
and also make this async
awesome
so for right now we finish everything we
need for our content script file but
obviously things aren't going to show in
the ui we can check that out right here
and as you can see
there's nothing in the ui because
everything we've been doing so far has
been manipulating the dom right here to
add the icon
add some logic to get us ready
to create a ui for our extension
let's go ahead and start making some ui
component shows starting out with some
bookmarks from clicking the edition
button in the youtube player that we
added
now the first thing we need to figure
out on any given page is if it's a
youtube video page or not if it is we're
going to want to fetch any bookmarks we
may have from chrome storage
and if it's not we'll just want to
display some messaging saying it's not a
youtube page if you open the chrome
extension on a page that is not youtube
so to do this we're going to add a
utility function
that's going to allow us to decipher
that logic so we're actually going to
grab our utility function to
find the active tab that the user is on
through google chrome documentation
i'm going to go ahead and use this
example right here which
helps us retrieve the currently focused
tab from the chrome documentation
and
since i have the google chrome pieces
extension over every code block whether
it's in documentation or stack overflow
i'm able to directly save on pieces with
this icon that shows up
at the top right of any code block i'm
going to go ahead and save it and then
i'm going to go back to my vs code
and refresh my pieces tree i can go
ahead and insert this snippet which is
the newest one and i'm also going to
rename the snippet
to active
tab chrome
amazing and pieces automatically
classified this as javascript because it
was able to decipher that from some
machine learning
i'm going to go ahead and delete this
background.js comment
and awesome we now have a function that
grabs the current tab but also i want to
make sure i'm exporting this function so
i'm going to add export
and then what i want to do is open up
the popup.js file
and over here we're going to want to
import that function at the very top
so we can use it here so i'm going to
import
get active tab url
from
utils
utils.js
and i actually don't think the
documentation called it this so i'm
going to go ahead and change
the function name so it matches
so go to
utils.js and change that to that awesome
now the event we want to listen to when
opening the popup.js file is the dom
content loaded event which is right here
this event is a native window event that
fires when an html document has
initially been loaded it's essentially
when we want to load all our bookmarks
and show them so we're going to type the
following to do so what we're going to
do is
grab our active tab function first
and we're going to
look at the user's current active tab
which we already have the function for
from in the utils
it's an async function so we're going to
async await this
and then after that we're going to grab
the query parameters to help us identify
the video
if you remember
each youtube video has a unique
identifier after the question
mark or the query parameter
and we're going to grab that
we're going to use the url search params
to be able to get the unique identifier
for each video
and to get the unique identifier
we're going to create a current video
variable and do url parameters.get
v
and this is just based off of what the
youtube video urls look like
now our active tab url
should have youtube.com
watch because any specific youtube video
always has this in its url and we want
to make sure we're watching a youtube
video when our chrome extension has any
logic with bookmarks
and we want to make sure this current
video variable is truthy meaning
this get actually returned something
other than
undefined or any falsy value
and then what we want to do is we want
to get any current video bookmarks
from chrome storage if you remember
we're
setting chrome storage with the current
video as a key
and then all the bookmarks as a value
that is jsonified
and in order for us to retrieve those
bookmarks we need to use the chrome
storage api to get them so to do that
we're going to grab
the video bookmarks using chrome storage
sync get
and we're going to get it with the
current video unique identifier which is
the youtube videos unique identifier in
the url
and then
we are going to
set a current video bookmarks variable
which is going to contain all those
jsonified
current videos and in order for us to
pass this to any function or write some
custom logic to show bookmarks
we're going to have to
json.parse
any bookmarks that are saved in chrome
storage since it's in json and we can't
really work with that
but
if there are no bookmarks or chrome
storage doesn't return anything we're
just going to want to return an empty
array now
we're going to have to
pass this over to the view bookmarks
function
which is basically going to help us view
any bookmarks in our extension
that chromestorage.getreturns
but before that i'm just going to put a
comment right here so we remember
we want to handle this else condition
which basically is for the scenario
where we're not on a youtube.com video
page
or current video returns
a full c value
so what we're going to want to do is add
a message that says this is not a
youtube video page
and let's just go back to
chrome to look at what that might look
like
so
this is our ui currently
we have this container class right here
that encapsulates
and will eventually encapsulate all the
bookmarks we have it has this container
class name in it
what we're going to want to do is get
that class name so
we're just going to do this in the
console before we actually do it in code
just to make sure it works
the class was called container and
that's just from the css in the
boilerplate so you don't have to worry
about it
or the html rather
so when we wrote this
document.getelementsbyclassname
container and then grab
the first element in the html collection
we get this element right here which is
containing all these other
elements within it
and what we want to do here is basically
specify in the html
on pages that are not youtube.com so
this is actually a youtube video page
we don't want to display this message
but i just want to show how this is
going to look
we're going to want to put a new div
class
that says this is not a youtube video
page
and let's just see if that works will
this change the extension the way we
want it to
container is not ah so what we need to
do over here
is actually encapsulate this in a
variable
we're gonna set this equal container
and now let's try that
and it changed the extension to show
that this is not a youtube video page
so the way we're going to do this
dynamically in our code is basically put
all the code we just put in our console
to test this out
within our else condition so every time
we're not on a youtube video page
or this returns a falsie value
we want to show that this is not a
youtube video page when we try to open
up the chrome extension in those
scenarios so we're going to say const
container equals document dot get
elements by class name
right
there grab that container class
first element
and then set the inner html
set that equal to
div class equals title title just adds
some styling
that's going to make it look slightly
nicer there's nothing
super special about the styling i have
and since we tested it there shouldn't
be really any surprises here it should
pretty much work
as expected
so let's go ahead and give this
extension a reload
it shouldn't show the message for this
page it doesn't but if we go to a
non-youtube page
it's going to say this is not a youtube
video page amazing
so let's go back to
our code and we're going to want to
write this view bookmarks function so
if it does meet the conditions of being
on a youtube.com watch page
and as you can see
that's from
any page that is a video page it has
youtube.com watch on it
and
url
params.get
return something so it's a truthy value
we're going to want to view the
bookmarks associated with that video so
let's go ahead and call the view
bookmarks function
and pass it all the current video
bookmarks
and we're going to go ahead and write
the logic that's going to help us
populate the ui
with all the bookmarks we grab from
chrome storage
so to do that
we're going to
pass it current bookmarks
and we're gonna set a default argument
of an empty array just in case nothing
is passed to it
it's just going to return or show no
bookmarks and
we're going to grab a
bookmark element
again this is just from the html that
i have given you
so it's not anything you need to worry
about if you want to try this out on
your own you could try it out in the
console
just to save some time here i'm just
going to write the code here and you can
go ahead and copy it
but again it's just knowing how to work
with the dom and inspecting the elements
to figure out
how to do this
what i'm doing right here is basically
saying okay if there are any bookmarks
let's just set it to nothing so we're
not displaying anything we're going to
reset the whole thing since we're
calling this function to view bookmarks
and we're going to have new bookmarks
being passed in which is the current
bookmarks
and we're going to say if the current
bookmarks length is greater than zero
meaning
if there are current bookmarks and it's
just not an empty array
let's go ahead and iterate over all
those bookmarks and show them in our
ui so to do that we're going to iterate
over every bookmark in a loop
and then
we're going to grab the bookmark through
indexing so current bookmarks
with whatever iteration we are in the
loop
and then what we're going to have to do
from here
is call another function
add new bookmark which is going to add a
new bookmark row to
our pop-up i'm going to go ahead and
remove this comment
and we're going to add new bookmark
we're going to pass it the bookmark
element up here which is going to
populate all our bookmarks well it's
going to be where we add each of our
rows
and i'm going to pass it each specific
bookmark so we're going to add one
bookmark at a time and call this
function every time we're adding a
bookmark
but before that what we want to do is if
there are no bookmarks a show meaning
current bookmarks is just an empty array
we're going to want a message that says
there are no bookmarks here so we're
going to set
a message using italics
saying no bookmarks
to show
before we move on and add individual
bookmarks to
our pop-up let's go ahead and check if
this condition works where there's no
bookmarks to show and since we haven't
added any bookmarks to this youtube
video that i'm looking at right now it
should work i'm going to go ahead and
reload my extension
yep there it is no bookmarks to show
amazing
so now we're going to want to finally
handle the case where we have bookmarks
to show
and this is going to allow us to start
seeing bookmarks in our ui
so the first thing we're going to do is
go to our add new bookmark function and
it's going to accept
bookmark
bookmarks
element
and it's going to accept
a bookmark
and then what we're going to do from
here
is we're going to create two elements so
one element is going to be
for the title which is going to display
in the ui of each bookmark
and then one element is going to be
the whole bookmark element that will
contain the title
will contain the delete button and will
contain the play button
so let's go ahead and create the
bookmark
title element
and then after this one we're also going
to create
the
new bookmark element
which will encapsulate
all these other elements that
are part of a bookmark row
from here for our bookmark title element
we're going to want to display
what the bookmark is and give it a title
so
we actually already created the title
the title is the description of the
bookmark if you remember in our bookmark
object there's a timestamp and a
description so we're going to set our
text content
to the description which is
bookmark.description
and then
our class name is going to be bookmark
title
element.classname
and that will be set equal to bookmark
title and this is just going to add some
css
that is already in our boilerplate code
now for the general component that is
going to encapsulate all the play button
the title the delete button anything
else you might want to add
we're going to do a couple things the
first thing we're going to do is
give it an id of bookmark element
or bookmark
with the bookmark time and this is going
to guarantee a
unique
id for each element that is a row so if
you save any bookmark what's going to
happen is there's going to be a row
associated with each bookmark which is
our new bookmark element
and there's going to be an id set for
that row which will be the bookmark
along with the time and that'll help us
uniquely identify any specific row in
the ui and that's later going to be used
to delete
elements when we're deleting a specific
bookmark
and then we're going to set a class name
which was is going to help with some
styling
that's going to be set to a bookmark
class
and then we're going to set an attribute
which is going to help us with playing a
video
because
basically we're going to want to know
the timestamp
of any specific bookmark so when we play
the video
we know where to set the video player at
what time we want to set it out and the
attribute of the bookmark element will
help us find that
and the final things we want to do here
is since we know the new bookmark
element is encapsulating all these other
things
we want to append child
bookmark title element
so it displays within the new bookmark
element
and then we have this bookmarks element
that is passed in
and we're gonna
append our
new bookmark element which is this
element that's encapsulating all the
other things
inside that since it's the container
so now if we go back to our ui
and we give this a reload just in case
let's just go to a new video
and if i press plus in this video
we see a
new row it says bookmark at one hour 54
minutes
and we could add another row if we want
[Music]
and it gives us that same row
we're going to handle the case of the
deletion there's an add it's just going
to set at zero seconds bookmark it zero
zero zero awesome so that works
so now
let's go back
work on some additional functionality
right now we have no functionality
associated with each bookmark yet so we
can't play any particular time stamped
bookmark we can't delete a bookmark and
the next thing we want to add is the
play button so to do this we're going to
add a play button to each bookmark that
will go directly to this timestamp that
we have saved for each video to start
off we're going to have to add a
function that is going to add an icon
for a play button listen for a click and
call a function or event listener that
will perform the logic to set a video at
a particular timestamp the function will
end up looking something like what we're
going to code right here in a second
and we're going to keep it super generic
because it's going to be used for both
our delete
and play functionality
so the function's going to take
a source attribute
an event listener
and
a control parent
element
and when we say control elements in our
code it means the play button the delete
button we're just calling those control
elements
so we're going to create a control
element
and this is just
one particular functionality we're going
to call a singular control element
so in this specific case we're going to
have a play button but again this is a
generic function so think of this as
like a play button a delete button we
want this singular control element will
be one of those
and then those control elements
will be linked to a image in our assets
folder
so if we want a play button
what we're going to link to is
asset slash
play dot png and our schema is super
predictable
for this
so all we're going to do is assets plus
src
plus
dot png
and there's definitely a better way of
doing this you can go back and work on
the code after this video but we're just
going to keep it super simple for right
now
we're going to give it a title that is
the same
as our
source attribute
or what we passed in this source so
what's going to get passed in here is
play edit
delete whatever and
the title will be set to that so in this
particular case for play it will be set
as play
we're going to add a
event listener
and that event listener will listen for
a click
and we're going to pass it a function
that is going to be performed on that
click and the last thing we want to do
is there's going to be a container for
all control elements
and we're passing that in into this
function and we're calling it control
parent element
so we're going to append
this singular control element
to the parent element
and the next thing we're going to want
to do is add the function call that will
add a play button a title and our event
listener to each individual bookmark so
in the add new bookmark function that we
coded earlier we're going to add a
couple lines of code here and these
couple lines of code are going to add
those control elements
so we're going to go ahead and create
the element that's going to hold all our
buttons
we're going to call it the controls
element
it's going to be a div just like these
other ones we're going to keep it super
simple
and then what we want to do is give this
some styling
we're gonna add the class name book
controls
and you're just gonna have to trust me
on this it exists
then what we want to do is set
our attributes using
the set bookmark attributes function
that we created
we're going to pass in play
the event listener is going to be called
on play and we're going to code that
later and then we're going to pass in
the controls element which is going to
be the parent element
and the last thing we want to do is
append this to our new bookmark element
and what we should see now is
this play button is going to show up in
our extension so let's check this out
let's give this a refresh over here
there we go we have the play button in
our extension but what we're going to
notice
is it's actually not going to work
let's go ahead and play this video
and we're going to try to get it back to
26 minutes 51 seconds it doesn't work
and the reason it doesn't work is we
still need to code the on play event
listener
so let's go ahead and do that
what we're going to do
is we're going to target the timestamp
attribute that we set earlier
so again you could check this out in
your console or inspect
if you want to
get a visualization of how this is going
to work but i'm going to go ahead and
type this for the sake of time
and we're going to get that timestamp we
set earlier
and then the second thing we're going to
want to do is grab the active tab and
that's just using the active tab
function
this is an async await function so we're
going to have to async await it i'm
going to add async to make this async
function
so we've actually run into a problem now
we need to send the content script a
message to manipulate the youtube player
to set it at the time stamp that the
bookmark is placed on so in this file
we're going to have to add that
message
let's go ahead and send a message to the
content script
and this is going to follow
the same pattern
of how we did it with
our background script
up missing comma there
we're going to have type of play that's
going to be our event type
and then the value is going to be
bookmark time
and then in our content script we're
going to have to be able to read this
message so what we're going to do is add
a condition to our on message listener
here and we're going to say if the type
is play
let's set the youtube player
time
equal to the value that's passed in so
basically let's just take a look at this
for a second
if it's sending a message of type play
and the value is the bookmark time then
what we want to do is take that value
and set it to the youtube player's
current time which will
make it the time of the bookmark and
let's go ahead and see if this works
i'm going to go ahead and reload my
extension
and let's go ahead and go to the
extension we have a bookmark at 26
minutes 51 seconds it's currently at 48
minutes 30 seconds
let's hit that play button it goes back
to 26 minutes 51 seconds
and now if we also hit this addition
button anywhere in the video
we should get a new bookmark
we have two hours 21 minutes 22 seconds
now let's go forward
let's press play here and it goes back
to that time awesome so now our play
button works
the last functionality we want to build
is the ability to delete a bookmark
which will be super similar to what we
did for the play button the first thing
we're going to want to do is go to our
popup.js file and we're going to add the
delete button to our controls element
with the code in our add new bookmark
function to set bookmark attributes so
let's go ahead and do that we're going
to
pass and delete
our on delete event listener and then
the parent
controls element and since we set the on
delete function as the event listener we
need to code some operations that are
going to take care of our deletion
so we already know we're going to use
this active tab that we used over here
so let's go ahead and already create
this an async function ahead of time
let's grab the user's active tab
and then what we're going to want to do
is grab the timestamp attribute that we
set earlier
and it's going to be the same code from
up here so i'm just going to copy and
paste
there we
go then what we're going to also want to
do is grab the element that we want to
delete
so if you remember
i created a specific id linked to
timestamps
what we're going to want to do is grab
elements by that id so we can delete
them
so bookmark
plus the bookmark time will give us the
element we want to delete
and then what we're going to do is
delete that element
by going to the parent node
and then removing the child which will
be the element we want to delete
and then the final thing we're going to
want to do here is send a message to our
content script
saying we want to perform a deletion
type of
delete
and then the value is going to be
bookmark time
and there's one final thing we want to
do here this send message function uh
from the chrome's tabs api actually
takes a callback function optionally
and we're going to pass one in which is
going to be our view bookmarks function
and that's just going to refresh our
bookmarks so any deletions show up
immediately then in our content script
we're gonna add another condition
which is basically gonna ingest that
delete message
[Music]
so we're going to say else if
type
equals
delete
the current video bookmarks will be
equal to
current video bookmarks
filter and we're going to filter by time
so the time is not equal to the value
being passed in because that's a value
we're deleting
and then the final thing we want to do
is sync chrome storage
so
if this page reloads
this deleted bookmark does not show up
we're in gonna jsonify
our bookmarks
and
that should work the last thing we want
to do is add a way to send the updated
bookmarks back to our popup.js file in
order to display the most recent
bookmarks
and we'll do the following to do that
we're going to send a response
of current video bookmarks
so now we can go ahead and try out
deleting a bookmark with a reload of our
extension and it should start working
so i'm going to go back to our chrome
browser
reload our extension
and
if we go ahead and delete a bookmark
we're going to see that they're deleted
if we go ahead and add a bookmark
we're going to see there's a new
bookmark
it's at a different timestamp the
youtube player is at a different
timestamp if we play
it goes back to the timestamp of the
bookmark
if we want to delete again it's going to
delete
the last thing we're going to want to do
is distribute our extension however i'm
not going to quite go over that in this
video because google gives great
documentation that serves as a
step-by-step guide on how to go about
publishing your chrome extension to the
google web store for anyone to download
and with that the video is over you know
everything you have to do in order to
create a modern web extension using
manifest v3 and i'll see you next time